representatives of four Western
countries walking out of a meeting of
U.N security Council Members Russia
organized the informal meeting to
discuss the transfer of children from
Ukraine to Russia controversially it
invited Russia's children's commissioner
Maria luvabolova to speak by video link
she was issued an arrest warrant by the
international criminal court at the same
time last month as the Russian President
Vladimir Putin accused of organizing the
Abduction of children
she though said they were being rescued
Al jazeera's Blurred the faces of
children who are now in Russia who
appeared in a video that she played to
the meeting
[Music]
I want to stress that unlike the
Ukrainian side we don't use children for
propaganda
when she spoke to reporters the U.S
ambassador to the United Nations
condemned the participation of Miss
Louvre belova a woman who has been
charged with war crimes who has been
involved in deporting and removal of of
children
from their homes to Russia so
controversy again and these are only the
first few days of Russia's presidency of
the un's security Council but there was
some hope for Ukrainian families when
the Russian official who the
international criminal court consider a
war crime suspect spoke she said that if
Ukrainian families request it then
children will be transferred back James
Bay's Al Jazeera of the United Nations